معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس ما
الجديد الجديد هو استمرار القصف المدفعي
المتقطع حقيقه مريم على اكثر من منطقه في
المنطقه الوسطى وايضا في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه اذا ما بدانا من المنطقه الوسطى
البريش تتعرض منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر الى
قصف مدفعي شديد ومتواصل حتى هذه الساعه
نستطيع ان نرى اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد
من اكثر من منطقه في البريج وكذلك منطقه
المغرا التي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
استهدفها صباح هذا اليوم واستهدف منصات
لاطلاق الصواريخ كانت موجوده في احدى
المناطق هناك كما ان منطقه جحر الديك
تتعرض لقصف مدفعي وهذه هي ايضا المنطقه
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه التي نشاهدها الان
على الشاشه هذه المنطقه الواقعه في الجنوب
نوب الشرقي لمدينه غزه ما بين جحر الديك
والمناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه لحي الشجاعيه
تشهد ايضا منذ ساعات الصباح قص مدفعيا
يبدو ان الان هنالك انفجار كبير
وقعه هذه غاره جويه الان على منطقه
الشجاعيه اذا غاره جويه الان في هذه
الدقائق تستهدف منطقه الشجاعيه حي
الشجاعيه الواقع شرق مدينه غزه نشاهد هذا
الانفجار الضخم عبر عدسه الكاميرا نشاهده
حتى بالعين المجرده يبدو انه كان ناجم عن
غاره جويه لانه في الاجواء نسمع ايضا هدير
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تحوم
في اجواء المنطقه اذا هذه الغاره الجويه
الان تحدث في منطقه حي الشجاعيه في
المنطقه تقريبا الجنوبيه منها المنطقه
الوا وقعه بين جحر الديك والمناطق الشرقيه
الجنوبيه لحي الشجاعيه هذه المنطقه حقيقه
مريم تتعرض منذ يوم امس لغارات جويه عنيفه
وبعض هذه الغارات كما كنا اشرنا يوم امس
كانت على علو منخفض للغايه بمعنى اننا
شاهدنا طائرات الاف 16 وهي تخترق اجواء
قطاع غزه على علو منخفض وتنفذ غارات جويه
كالتي حدثت الان لكن هذه كانت من لو شاهق
لمقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه واضح بان
القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول استهداف مناطق
بعينها في حي الشجاعيه يبدو انها لم
تستهدفها في خلال العمليات العسكريه
الكبرى وبعض هذه الغارات الجويه حقيقه
مريم تستهدف مناطق قريبه جدا بمحاذاه
السياج الامني وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاول او يستمر في عمليه التدمير الممنهجه
ل عشرات او لالاف الشقق السكنيه في هذه
المنطقه في محاوله لتدميرها كليا ومنع
الفلسطينيين من العوده اليها بعد انتهاء
هذه الحرب على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يسعى الى ان يحولها الى منطقه عازله الى
منطقه امنيه الى عمق امني واستراتيجي
لمنطقه غلاف غزه تحديدا في المناطق
القريبه من السياج الامني وتحديدا قباله
البلدات الاسرائيليه في منطقه غلاف غزه
لان هنام لك التجز كبير من جانب السكان
الاسرائيليين للعوده الى بلدتهم لكن رغم
كل هذا القصف المدفعي والغارات الجويه
مريم المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت اي تقول
نحن هنا نحن موجودون سواء كان ذلك في
الميدان في القتال المتواصل مع القوات
الاسرائيليه في اكثر من محور واكثر من
مكان في داخل قطاع غزه في المنا حتى في
اقصى المناطق الشماليه للقطاع في بيت لهيه
وفي بيت حنون وفي العطاطه حيث كانت
الاشتباكات ايضا قائمه على اشدها صباح هذا
اليوم وانها قادره ايضا على اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه غلاف غزه وكما شاهدنا حتى
يوم امس هذه القصف الصاروخي الذي طال حتى
مدينه اسدود وقبل ذلك على راس السنه
الجديده ايه القصف الصاروخي الذي طال
مدينه تل ابيب وهذا القصف الصاروخي في خضم
هذه العمليه العسكريه يصيب الاسرائيليين
بكثير من التوجس بكثير من القلق حول ما
فعلته اسرائيل عمليا من خلال لهذه العمليه
العسكريه التي لم تحقق بحسب كثير من
المراقبين العسكريين الاسرائيليين اهدافها
لا لم تحقق الاهداف العسكريه منها بمعنى
انها لم تخمد المقاومه ايه على الميدان لم
تخمد نيران الصواريخ التي تطلق تطلق من
قطاع غزه وتصيب العمق الاسرائيلي ولم تنجح
في تحقيق الهدف المعلن ايضا من جانب
المستوى السياسي الاسرائيلي مريم وهو
باستعاده ال المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في
داخل قطاع غزه وبالتالي ستكون هذه الليله
ايضا مظاهره كبرى في ميدان المحتجزين
والمفقودين قباله وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه في تلي ابيب هذه المظاهره
التي سوف تستمر ل 2 ساعه سيشارك فيها الاف
الاسرائيليين في محاوله للضغط على المستوى
السياسي الاسرائيلي والتعجيل في ابرام
اتفاق لاستعاده المحتجزين الاسرا يين داخل
قطاع غزه الى اسرائيل على اعتبار ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي وعدت العائلات
الاسرائيليه بان العمليه العسكريه سوف
تحرك هذا الملف وسوف تاتي بنتائج
وبثمن عنهم لم تحقق هذا الهدف وبالتالي
واضح بان الحراك الشعبي في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
و ومن قبل عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين سوف يتواصل وسوف يتصاعد هذا
الحراك في قادم الايام وتحديدا هذا اليوم
الذي ستستمر فيه هذه التظاهر ل 24 ساعه
متواصله حتى دخول هذه الحرب يومها المئ
هذا الصوت الذي سمعناه قبل ثوان الياس هل
هي غره
جديده هو قصف مدفعي جديد حقيقه مريم اي
يعني واضح بان هذا القصف المدفعي يتركز
على المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه بالتحديد
ما زلنا نرى اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد من
المنطقه الواقعه
في منطقه جحر الديك ومدينه غزه اذا هذه هي
الان القصف المدفعي الجديد الذي نراه عند
هذه الابر
نعم الان تسمعين هذا الهدير وهذا الصوت
الانفجار
الكبير يبدو انه ناجم ايضا عن غاره الجويه
بمرافقه القصف المدفعي لكن احيانا مريم
عندما يتز يتكثف القصف المدفعي ويتزامن
ايضا مع الغارات الجويه هذا ربما يكون
مؤشر على ان القوات الاسرائيليه التي تعمل
في الميدان وفي البر يبدو انها عالقه في
مازق وتطلب هذا الدعم والاسناد الجوي
والمدفعي من جانب القوات البريه الموجوده
في منطقه غلاف غزه من اجل تخليص الجنود
الاسرائيليين في البر وفي المناطق التي
يعملون فيها عسكريا في داخل القطع لذلك
نتساءل عن طبيعه وحجم و فوت ايضا المعارك
البريه التي شهدتها هذه المناطق في الوقت
القريب قبل ان تتعرض لهذا الكم من الغارات
والقصف المدفعي
الياس مريم 100 يوم 100 يوم من الغارات
الجويه العنيفه الذخيره الكبيره حتى
المؤسسات الدوليه التي تحدثت قبل شهرين عن
ان اسرائيل يعني القت بقنابل تزن بحجم قنب
دولتين نوويتين ربما اصبحت ثلاث او اربع
قنابل نوويه من حيث حجم التفجيرات ولكن لا
يبدو ان اسرائيل قادره على تحقيق صوره
انتصار واحده تظهرها للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
بانها حققت انجازا ما في ميدان المعركه
وهذا يقوله كثير من المحللين والمراقبين
العسكريين في اسرائيل حقيقه مريم ويقولون
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبدو انه يراوح
مكانه ولم يحقق اي انجاز في تقويد حركه
حماس سواء كان ذلك على المستوى العسكري
وعلى المستوى مستوى حكم حماس في قطاع غزه
لذلك نحن نرى هذا المشهد الان امامنا عبر
العدسه وهذه اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد من
اكثر من موقع في مدينه غزه وفي جباليا وفي
بيت لاهيا وفي المناطق الجنوبيه وفي
المخيمات الوسطى هذه كلها مؤشر على ان
العمليات العسكريه اي في اوجها في ذروتها
ما زالت مستمره وان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ما زالت قادره على التصدي وعلى المقاومه
وعلى مواجهه الجيش الاسرائيلي ووجود هذه
اعمده الدخان تؤكد على ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يحسم المعركه حتى في هذه
المناطق ولا حتى في المناطق الشماليه ولا
في المناطق الوسطى ولا حتى في المناطق ال
الجنوبيه لانه لو انه حسم وسيطر ميدانيا
وناريه على هذه المناطق لما كنا نشاهد كل
هذه ال الدخان وكل اعمده الدخان وكل هذا
القصف الم والغارات الجويه المستمره على
مدار الساعه وعلى مدار الايام ونحن نستعد
للدخول لليوم المئه من عمر الحرب وكثير من
كتاب الاعمده حقيقه مريم خاصه محللين في
المجال العسكري يقولون بصراحه بان على
علينا ان نعترف كما يقولون بالحقيقه
الواضحه بان اسرائيل لم
تحقق اهداف هذه الحرب لا على الصعيد
العسكري وعلى على صعيد استعاده المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين الموجودين في داخل قطاع غز
وقع هذه الكلمه 100 يوم من عمر هذه الحرب
الياس وانت تشير الى ما يكتبه كتاب العمود
والمحللون السياسيون والعسكريون
الاسرائيليون كيف يبدو وقع هذه الكلمه 100
يوم وصداها في الاوساط السياسيه
الاسرائيليه والعسكريه والشعبيه
كذلك يبحثون عن صوره نصر خلال مه يوم ولا
يجد دونها ويتحدثون عن شراسه المعارك
ويتحدثون عن ان حركه حماس لم ترفع ايديها
م مستسلمه وان المقاومه لم ترفع الرايه
البيضاء ويتحدثون عن مخاوف
وتوجساتها القوات الاسرائيليه او اعاده
انتشار القوات الاسرائيليه في المناطق
التي احتلتها في داخل قطاع غزه لن يجدي
نفعا لانه سيترك فراغا يمكن المقاومه
الفلسطين من استعاده هذه المناطق من
استعاده السيطره العسكريه على هذه المناطق
ومن استعاده سيطرتها السلطويه المدنيه
حكمها في داخل قطاع غزه في المناطق
الشماليه هذا ما قاله يواف ليمور بالامس
في احد مقالاته التحليليه التي توصف بانها
جريئه حقيقه لانها تضع الاصبع وتشير
بالبنان على خقات الجيش الاسرائيلي حقيقه
في تحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب عندما قال بان
اسرا
لم تقدم صوره انتصار واحده في عمر هذه
الحرب التي تدخل يومها المئ شكرا جزيلا لك
الياس كرام في استعراض للموقف العسكري من
خلال عدستك وما تلتقطه من غلاف غزه لما
يجري داخل القطاع شكرا لك حتى الان